my research that you'll hear about here
in a moment basically concludes by
saying that when people are reminded of
money they don't behave pro socially
they prefer to be alone rather than with
others and they they're very much more
interested in an isolated insulated
orientation towards the world and not so
much one that's connected and pro-social
and thinking about others so with that
let me get started because I'm gonna
develop the theory as I show you some of
our experiments hmm okay we did figure
this out all right what would happen in
these experiments is subjects come into
my laboratory and we're trying to find
out how people represent the construct
of money by differentially activating
that construct in some subjects and then
other subjects we're not going to
activate the construct of money and then
we're gonna test to see people's
behavior subsequently and see whether
they vary as a function of whether
they'd earlier been reminded of money or
not
and so these initial experiments for our
perhaps clumsy attempts at trying to
remind people of the construct of money
in some very big ways so in this first
experiment our subjects came into the
laboratory where they were met with a
Confederate who is really someone who
works for my lab she's posing as in this
experiment this Confederates posing as
another subject they meet and we say
that the purpose of this experiment is
to see how different people's
personality traits play out when they're
interacting in a in a sort of game-like
scenario and since we're here in the
business school we're using economic
type games so subjects in this
experiment
okie-dokie multiple things going on here
subjects in this experiment are coming
in and they're gonna play Monopoly and
in this set of subjects some of the
subjects play Monopoly with the
Confederate and then the Confederate
leaves and they're left with 4,000
dollars of Monopoly money which we in a
small lab meeting and decided seemed
like a lot of monopoly money really sir
how to think about it but that seemed
like a lot and we told them that they
were going to have this here and it was
for later the important thing about this
for later is that subjects very much
knew you can test this with post testing
that they had not earned that money per
se they have not been endowed with that
money and they were not being rewarded
for their performance in the game rather
me just told them that this money was
for later so subjects in the 200 money
$200 money condition are also left with
a little bit of money on the side of
their table but this was deemed again
with that same lab meeting by being just
a little bit of money and then other
subjects still when the game is cleaned
up are left with no additional money so
for these last subjects the construct of
money should be starting to decay from
their minds so to review all the
subjects had been having a monopoly game
interaction with a Confederate when that
game is cleaned up some subjects are
left with a lot of money seated on their
their table on which they're working
other subjects are left with a little
bit of money and still other subjects
are not left with any money so the idea
of money for them should be starting to
decay or lessen so in this first
experiment we wanted to test whether
people who were differentially reminded
of money might behave differentially Pro
socially and we tested that in the
domain of helping so in this experiment
a second Confederate now comes into play
subjects are seated in the room in which
they played Monopoly and the
experimenter says you know what this lab
is extremely busy we have a lot of
different things going on and we're
gonna have to move you from this lab
room over to a lab room that's across
the way so while they get up and they're
moving they cross into a middle open
space much like this where they're
intercepted by the second Confederate
who was acting as if she's playing a
hurried experimenter she has a variety
of different office supplies in her
hands including a manila envelope with
those little tiny golf pencils that we
use to fill in scantrons
at universities she drops that bag of
pencils right in front of the subject
and we see how many pencils the subject
helps her
pick out you see that the amount of
helpfulness varies as a function of how
strongly subjects have been reminded of
money earlier subjects who had sat at a
desk for which for five minutes four
thousand dollars of Monopoly money was
placed were the least helpful of all the
groups in this experiment subjects who
had not been reminded of money very
strongly in our control condition our
being the most helpful and subjects in
the low money condition are falling
somewhere in between the two so here we
have initial evidence that being
reminded of money then impacts people's
pro-social behaviors in the form of
helping we decided to try this a number
of different ways in this next
experiment we orchestrated it so that
the helping demands were clear because
the problem with that initial experiment
is it's not totally clear to the subject
perhaps that help is needed when a
subject is walking across an
experimental laboratory and some sort of
you know accident happens with papers
and pencils on the floor it's not clear
that it's the subjects job to be helping
so we wanted in this next experiment to
very much make clear that help is needed
so here's what we did we actually
changed the manipulation of activating
the construct of money to be one that's
very clean it's also a little bit boring
when we have our subjects in the money
condition coming into the laboratory and
because we say that we're interested in
different marketing slogans and ad copy
we'd like to know how people think about
and arrange words into meaningful
phrases so we would have subjects take a
look at a scrambled phrase like is
outside cold desk it and they'd have to
look at that and determine that four of
those five letters make a meaningful
phrase you do this a few times it
becomes very fast now and in this
neutral condition you can see that the
phrase would be it's cold outside so in
this task subjects are D scrambling
thirty neutral phrases neutral meaning
they're not money related at all in our
money condition when you have subjects D
scrambling thirty phrases fifteen of
which are related to the construct of
money this one
here is anyone I paint all right there
we go ding ding ding high paying salary
it's important to note that some of the
phrases in this money prime are in fact
talking about having money like a high
paying salary but still others are
talking about money as it sort of flows
out things like he paid the bills this
is what happens again a little bit of
dramatization is going on but we now
have the experimenter come in until the
subject you know what this lab room is
extremely busy and we don't have another
place to put someone else and she's
gonna have to sit in this room here with
you so we bring in again a Confederate
someone working for the lab and she's
now presented to the subject as another
subject in a different experiment who
just doesn't have a place to fit so that
Confederate sits down in the same room
as our real subject and the experimenter
says I'm gonna leave you two for a
little while I've got to run down the
hall things are really busy I'll be back
in a little bit so she leaves and now
the two of them are working on their
different questionnaires after a few
seconds the Confederate says to the
subject I don't really understand what
to do here can you help me very clear
very explicit help is needed and the
idea is this it's like a search your
word task but it's done with numbers and
so as the participant would help this
the the Confederate the Confederate
would continue to feign confusion I
don't understand can you only go up and
down Oh only left and right oh no not
only and so on and so forth and so at
the same time we are surreptitiously
timing how long the participant is being
helpful to the Confederates and here's
what you see that when subjects had
earlier been reminded of money they are
giving less help to a confused peer then
with subjects had not earlier been
reminded of money this is on the y axis
the second spent helping and in fact
when you do a more gross analysis in
which you see whether subjects even
tried to help or not you see in effect
there as well some subjects simply tried
simply did not try to help and said
something like I don't know
it's not my problem or I think you
should really figure it out so you see
it both in terms of gross willingness to
help and then how long they were helpful
we move now to a new context and ask the
question well maybe it's the case that
our money reminded participants were not
being helpful because we asked for help
in a very specific way we asked for help
in terms of time maybe people reminded
of money would be helpful if they could
be helpful in terms of money so we set
up to the following scenario in this
experiment the subjects come into the
laboratory and we say this is an
experiment that is coming at the end of
the semester and we only have quarters
to pay you with because the last
experiment that we ran use quarters
because of it had a pay-for-performance
design and that's all we have left sorry
really what this is for is so that our
subjects have eight quarters eight units
of money in order for them to have the
opportunity to donate later so we wanted
to give more of a nice continuous
measure of being able to donate so in
this experiment subjects come in and
they sit down and they do that's the
verbal task that you had heard about
before subjects filling out either the
neutral D scrambling task or the money -
scrambling task after which they do
several different filler questionnaires
and then the experimenter says actually
that's it the experiment is all done
thanks so much I know it's very boring
but this lab is interested in
personality perceptions and how they
relate to other personality perceptions
and so it's simply involved filling out
questionnaires this is what's called a
false debriefing a wonderful tool for
experimenters because then as
experimenters leaving the room she says
oh and by the way we are taking
donations for a university student fund
there's a box there in the back if you'd
like to donate subjects are now given a
private opportunity to donate and we
know they have money to do so because we
gave them a quarters earlier so here's
what you see
it's not the case that the subjects in
the earlier experiments weren't helpful
because of it involved time and not
money here subjects reminded of money
are donating less of their money that
they've just newly earned to a
university student fund relative to
subjects who had not been earlier
reminded of money so so far what kind of
a theory do you think comes out of these
data what would you say would be the
theory that these data go towards I'm
gonna start cold calling I work in a
business school Andy Koch called me the
moment you mention it does that I say to
them that the theory is that the more
that the more the people are fixing on
money whether it's for time or for or
for actual you know having the more they
value it or the more they implicitly
attach themselves to it and wanna part
with it laughs okay Oh
interesting interesting okay so then
when subjects are reminded of money then
and and so they come to value their time
more as well in the earlier experiments
that was what I was you know million
before and then you did this one and I
thought that you know the same same
thing might apply but okay or more
broadly okay that's one that's one any
others Greg I think it just puts them in
a stingy frame money
stingy frame of mind so when people are
reminded of money they turn into little
Scrooge's huh yeah having and yeah
you've got to give it away yeah release
yeah you got to give it away you've got
a release okay good Tara Tara yeah I
mean I work for a company where this is
actually a big deal we're constantly ask
for money and there's a certain
detachment I know I meet with my time so
when talk to Jennifer a lot about this
but when people just come to money we
detach cuz we're constantly being
brushed I mean I think society is
constantly
of what we have to pay out you want to
feel value for something yeah I like
that so money elicits a detached sense
or attached
sort of mindset oh I like that I hadn't
heard the word detached before but that
really resonates with me yes this is
similar to Greg's comment but I think
the money thing creates an inward focus
and the inward focus is actually what
negatively impacts both the time and the
future release of the money nice nice
nice inner focus good hold on to that
and Jamie last one okay good okay so um
survey says
I give this talk all over doesn't this
just show that money makes people feel
selfish they make them feel selfish they
make them behave selfishly so survey
says most people will say that when you
look at these data they say well what
have you really shown us here money
makes people selfish stingy inner
focused viewing things at which they
have an own is more precious than maybe
things that other people have an own
yeah so we think that that's not
actually quite the answer that's and
part of an answer when we think actually
it looks a little bit more like this we
think that people reminded of money turn
into what we call self-sufficient beings
and in self-sufficiency people it's true
are not willing or they're become
reticent to help but they're also not
really willing to receive help from
others either so in my lab we were
developing the hypothesis that money
elicits a self sufficient orientation
and in this self sufficiency mode you
would see it in one form as being less
pro-social and less helpful but in
another form you might also see that
people are willing to work longer and
harder at the things that they value the
things that are their own personal goals
and in the and in that sense they would
be less interested in receiving help
from others so we did a series of
experiments to follow up on whether this
more self-sufficient mode had been
activated so here's one experiment in
this experiment again we did that verbal
task you'd heard about before it's nice
it's easy it's clean we know exactly
what it's doing psychologically here's
what we give subjects after this now our
subjects are left alone in a room with
something called the nine dot problem
anyone ever done the nine dot problem
yeah did you get it how long did it
stuff one right yeah it's often used in
organizations to get people to think
outside the box literally in this case
that's how the answer is is solved and
in this experiment our subjects are told
that they have the opportunity to ask
for help at any point all they have to
do is knock on a door and the
experimenter will come back in and give
them helpful tips or in fact a solution
so we wanted to know now a selfish
person would not want to give help to
other people but when she got into a jam
she'd be the first one to raise her hand
and say hey hey hey I need help come
help me out here
a self-sufficient person would perhaps
not be interested in helping other
people but would also be reticent to
accept help from others instead
preferring to work and try to solve
challenging tasks on their own and
that's in fact what you see subjects who
are reminded of money work longer and
harder at their own goals than subjects
who are not reminded of money so these
subjects here are refusing help in order
to work on a very challenging task one
that you might even say is very
frustrating and and then it became
bigger than than just about helping so
we did a series of other experiments
really trying to map this out so for
example in one of our other experiments
we had the opportunity to ask for help
be in the context just just a peer
relationship and so in that experiment
subjects are seated in a room working
again on a challenging problem this one
was actually unsolvable and it works out
great because you're not gonna solve it
so the experiment can go on for a long
time get good data that way we also then
have another peer come in and sit with
the subject and we tell them this peer
this person had just done the experiment
that you've just done and now he's here
to do a second experiment so now the
anticipate knows that this peer knows
what's going on and the experimenter
says I have to run down the hall I'm
gonna be away if you have any questions
you could probably ask him and so now
you see in that same experiment that
subjects reminded of money also work
longer and harder when trying to achieve
that than impossible goal even when they
could ask a friendly peer so then we
decided to say that we had a nice story
about money and helping but we thought
this idea of self-sufficiency was bigger
than that so in this experiment our
subjects come into the laboratory and
they're seated at a desk so they're
doing this individually they're seated
at a desk on which there's a big thick
packet of questionnaires that we want
them to fill out and often the corner of
that desk is a computer that's showing a
plain PC backdrop at first but then we
use a screen saver that comes on at a
certain point when they are filling out
those questionnaires to differentially
activate the construct of money so this
is one screensaver that comes on this is
a from a company called G leo soft and
if you go to their website it always
says our most popular screensaver ever
and don't know who has this on their
computer but happily and luckily for me
this screensaver comes in different
denominations and five different
currencies so when I collect data in
Europe and when I collect it in China
you can use the same screensaver
so as my subjects heads are bent down
working furiously on their
questionnaires often their visual
periphery is showing a screensaver this
one of money love luckily for me too the
same company makes a fish screensaver so
you see a very similar pattern this time
just with fish and for the purposes of
this experiment we wanted to ensure that
there wasn't something special about the
fish screensaver so we have a NOAA
screensaver control as well what happens
now is the experimenter says in this
experiment your next task is to have a
get-to-know-you conversation with
someone who's down the hall I'm gonna go
get that person oh why don't you grab
that chair pull it up and get ready for
the conversation
and we measure the distance between the
two chairs has preferred social intimacy
and this is what you see subjects we've
been reminded of money from that
screensaver put more physical distance
between themselves and another person
showing that they prefer more social
distance and certainly less intimacy so
yeah yes yes it is yes it is right it's
not like a fraction of an inch and you I
mean you sort of see okay this these
data were collected in Canada you get
sort of a physical distance you know
preferred distance but you can see that
the fish screensaver doesn't bring
people together which was secretly our
fear fish would make people want to come
together so people are putting the same
distance right in the fish and the
screen the fish in the blank screensaver
and then just more physical distance
when they've been reminded of money so
in this experiment this other experiment
we asked people whether they would in
the context of a work assignment prefer
to work alone or together and we made
this one a little bit tricky so in this
experiment subjects are now either
reminded of money fish or our blank
screensaver again and the context here
is that they have the opportunity to
work with someone else on an upcoming
advertising development task and we say
to random assignment they have been
chosen to be the one who gets to decide
work with the person down the hall or
work alone but we make it clear to them
that working alone means you do the
whole task yourself including working
alone working alongside someone else
then divides that labour up somewhat so
the question is where people prefer to
work alone even if it means that they
have to work harder and the answer is
definitely yes
so in our university undergraduates it
turns out that chance to work with
someone else on a boring task is jumped
on our undergraduates think that's a
fantastic idea
but this completely flips when our
subjects had been earlier reminded of
money now you see that even
they have to do more work than they
would otherwise yeah no they prefer to
be alone okay and in this experiment we
then decided to say hey wait a minute
wait a minute we had this led meeting
and we came to the conclusion that
probably what we'd been doing was wrong
headed because maybe when people are
reminded of money they do want to be
separate from others but all of the
others in our previous experiments were
strangers
there was a clumsy peer dropping things
in front of you are confused students
there was someone that you have to have
a get-to-know-you conversation with but
maybe when people are reminded of money
they really want to be close and
intimate with friends and family and we
had not tested that so we brought it
into the domain of leisure activities
and we asked these questions
first our subjects come into the lab and
they sit down at a desk and now they're
doing those irrelevant questionnaires
this time with a poster hanging above
their heads I worked at the University
of British Columbia and we have
beautiful colorful Canadian money in
this poster or two other beautiful
colorful posters as well sit underneath
and we ask these questions if you had to
choose one of the options in these pairs
what would you choose so we gave our
subjects a nice long list of different
kinds of options that unbeknownst to
them they didn't detect this one option
was for the self alone and the other
option was to do with others so we were
asking them at each moment with each
option do you want to be playing alone
or do you want to spend your playtime
with other people and what we see is
that even when they're thinking about
friends and family subjects reminded of
money
choose experiences for the self as
opposed to experiences to be done with
others so people reminded of money are
self-sufficient in the sense that
they're willing to work longer and
harder to perform tasks as long as they
can be alone and they're not helpful
towards others as a consequence there's
sort of a two pronged effect here data
here collected at
GSP at Stanford by some colleagues who
are in the organizational behavior group
showed that when people are reminded of
money this is Stanford GSB MBA students
they are reporting less willingness to
volunteer so willingness to volunteer on
items like I'd volunteer for an
organization without financial
compensation for myself that goes down
I'm unlikely to undertake work without
being paid agreement to that item would
go up when people were reminded of money
so you see support from other labs
showing that people reminded of money
are less interested in volunteerism you
see that similar effects are obtained in
India this was a replication done by an
Indian PhD student in psychology
subjects in India reminded of money then
said that they were less willing to lend
someone money for a movie give
directions to a store give someone a
ride to an event it was sort of a casual
event or give someone a ride to
something what was an important event
they were less linked to donate blood to
surgery and provide comfort during
surgery these data stand on in
particular for me because one of the
questions when you see these data of
mine are well this is like a North
American effect right you've got all
these subjects you said you worked in
Canada you clearly work in the US this
is just how North Americans think about
money but in fact in highly Kalista
collectivistic societies such as India
being reminded of money moves people
towards a less pro-social way of
behaving and responding to others it
replicates in adolescents as well this
young woman here is name is shreya
shriya's parents are bio engineers and
physicists and they take the magazine
science in which our data originally
appeared she read the article and
decided to try to replicate it among her
eighth grade colleagues so shreya here
reminded 8th graders of money or not and
then she asked them out of a hundred
dollars how much would you give to
charity
how much time would you be able would
you be willing to help a classmate with
some homework by the way this is shreya
here at Cooley it's her poster at the
science fair she not only won for the
state of Indiana she went all the way to
the Discovery Channel Science Nationals
on this project because it does
replicate so adolescents who are
reminded of money say that they would
donate less money out of a 100 dollar
windfall and they say that they would
donate less of their time to help a
classmate who needed help with homework
I'm now gonna bring you into a new line
of research in which we're trying to
extend the self sufficiency idea and in
this line of research we started asking
how far we could push the envelope with
this self-sufficient notion so people
who are self-sufficient feel like they
can do things on their own they don't
want help from other people and how
could you really really really really
really test that so we did it in the
context of pain in these experiments
subjects are either going to be given a
painful experience or reminded of pain
and I'll tell you that we did these
experiments all in China so that was
another big move for us trying to ensure
that the data that we're collecting in
North America aren't somehow overly
specific to North American cultures so
in this first experiment subjects come
into the lab individually and they
either count out yuan in the form of
$100 you one bills and a $100 bill is
like a 14 dollar bill in the United
States so it's like counting out tens or
twenties subjects and are in the paper--
condition similarly count out eighty
something's but those are 80 slips of
paper and in this experiment we're now
going to give subjects one of two other
conditions there is a famous task that
we use in social psychology called cyber
ball and it's an online interaction
tasks that can be rigged to either
represent a normal interaction with
other people online or represent an
interaction with people online that
feels very socially isolate
or excluding or ostracizing and so in
this experiment we've now randomly
assigned subjects to play the online
game either in a setting in which they
are playing normally and feel nice and
included or in a setting in which the
other players exclude and ostracize them
so this is what cyber ball looks like
you're just simply passing a ball it's a
very easy game and you could see that
you are the small hand down here and
when you pass them all to one of the
players he receives it throws it to
another one throws it back to you and so
on in our ostracism excuse me in our
ostracism version of the game subjects
are passed the ball twice in the first
seven tosses and then none subsequently
no other passes subsequently and in the
normal play condition it looks exactly
as you saw here passing the ball nice
and equally between and among all the
players when then asked subjects
immediately thereafter how did that feel
to you and we used a measure of social
distressed we said how much did you feel
valued or how much did you feel socially
rejected and you see that here counting
paper is like our control condition
so when subjects had been socially
ostracized they said it hurt relative to
when they had not been socially
ostracized
but when subjects had earlier been
counting money that effect went away
subjects who had been socially
ostracized said that it felt about the
same as subjects who had not been
socially ostracized suggesting that
people who are reminded of money aren't
bothered by the pain of social rejection
we ran a parallel study in the physical
realm in which we reminded subjects of
money or not
and then we place their hands in very
very hot water water that was bordering
on painfully hot and you see the effect
there as well subjects reminded of money
say that that hot water was not so hot
wasn't very painful
we now decided to flip this and ask
whether people who are socially rejected
or accepted have different feelings
about money so in this experiment
subjects come to the laboratory with
four others subjects and they all have a
get-to-know-you conversation then they
separate and go into small little
different rooms and each of them writes
down who among those four people that
they've met would they most like to have
their next task be with we don't care
what they say on those forums because at
this point the subjects are randomly
assigned to either be socially accepted
or socially rejected in the accepted
case the experimenter comes into the
room and says okay this is this very
strange
and this just never happens but everyone
shows you for the next task so
logistically it's just not gonna work we
will move on to something else
in the rejection condition the words are
the same with the exception of one no
one chose you it's just very strange
this never happens
logistically yeah this isn't gonna work
we'll have to move on
and so now everyone is moving on to a
new task either because they were so
likable or because they were not so
likable and in that next task we wanted
to ask about their desire for money so
we use three different indicators the
first one here drawing a $1 coin this is
a famous task that's been used for
nearly 60 years because it seems that
people who desire money more
perceptually represent the idea of money
as bigger so they draw coins as bigger
dollar bills as bigger it seems to
represent their desire for money we
wanted to support or bolster that with
two other indicators of desire for money
here we asked our Chinese subjects which
of these seven nice things in life would
you trade to be a millionaire
meaning give up for life that was clear
and then we'd really given our subjects
eight yuan for participating and we
asked them how much and and gave them an
opportunity to donate that money this is
all on one graph but all the differences
are significant you see that subjects
who had been socially rejected represent
coins as percent
largerr they're willing to trade more
beautiful things in life to be a
millionaire
and they actually give less money to a
local orphanage so when subjects are
people are feeling socially excluded
they want money more they're wanting to
grab it and desire it more and in the
very last study in this section I'm
gonna tell you about is trying to
understand the underlying underlying
dynamics of this money construct so here
we very specifically did something we
haven't done before I focus people on
money that they've lost or spent we have
generally been thinking about the money
construct in this big generic way we
just remind people of money with
monopoly money or with words or with a
screensaver but in this set of
experiments and I'll show you this one
here we focus people on not having that
money does it then do the same kinds of
effects or something different so here
our subjects in the neutral condition
come into our lab and they're given a
calendar of the last month and they
write down what that weather has been
for the last month so thinking about the
past and our subjects in our money
condition are similarly thinking about
the past that same month in fact but now
they're writing down their monetary
expenditures or monetary losses for the
month and then we do the same thing
we've done in an experiment I showed you
two back we have them go online and play
a game in which they're past the ball
normally and feel nice and socially
accepted or in which they're not past
the ball very frequently and they feel
socially rejected and then we ask them
how much pain they felt about that you
know that you see that now the effect is
reversed subjects who are thinking about
the money that they don't have feel
social pain more much much more in fact
then subjects who are just in our
control condition in which yeah it's
true being socially excluded hurts but
it hurts a lot more if you're thinking
about how you don't have money so one
thing that we've drawn upon this in this
latest line of research is that we're
picking up this idea that people feel
strong when they're reminded of money so
in those earlier experiments in which we
had subjects come in and count out like
tens and twenties
they reported to us on a long lengthy
list of how you feeling different
emotional states different ideas about
self-control different ideas about
self-esteem the only thing that pops is
this idea of strong subjects who had
been counting money so that they felt
strong relative to subjects who had not
been counting money and then when we
focused those people different people of
course but focus people on the money
they don't have then they said they
didn't feel strong they felt quite weak
so we're kind of coming to this idea
that being self-sufficient because
you're reminded of money means that you
feel strong and and robust as an
individual all right so now how are you
ship this effect I'm now gonna take a
page out of Louann docker and I'm going
to suggest that one way we might try to
remedy this is to get people focused not
on money but instead on time so in this
experiment and there is a series of
experiments here so I just come into the
laboratory and they're gonna be thinking
about donating their time or their money
to an organization called Hope lab and
we're gonna be hearing from Steve Cole
here later in the workshop today about
the work they do at Hope lab and we're
gonna be asking or the the researchers
asked the participants either to think
about donating their time first and then
money or donating money first and then
time and then they followed up with a
real donation campaign both in terms of
money and time so this is a hotel Hope
lab I didn't know is this your your oh
that's their old logo I we look forward
to this afternoon to see the new logo
our participants
I keep owning this study which is not
it's not my study the participants in
this experiment were UC Berkeley college
students and they see something like
this I don't know if you can see this
they're talking in this particular
campaign about a video game that
adolescents who have cancer can play and
it teaches them about their their
disease
how it progresses and how you can fight
it and you can fight it with these
shooters and the shooters represent of
course the different medical remedies
that you could that they could be taking
so what the idea is is that kids get
behind this video game and they become
more involved invested and aware of
their disease and so now the question is
to our college again not my Z college
students in this experiment how much do
you think this organization is doing a
good thing how much would you like to
volunteer to help them and some of the
subjects are asked how interested are
you in volunteering for Hope lab so
that's a time question first and then
asked how interested are you in making a
donation to Hope lab or those were
flipped and so then you'd have the money
ask condition first then there's a
twenty minute gap see other sub they're
doing other questionnaires and then you
see a variety of measures here they
Jennifer you're gonna have to help me
out with this box people were paying
with ten $1 bills and we serve dishes
you measured whether people actually
donated to Hope lab and in order to get
a time odd behavior measure we also
asked whether they were interested in
volunteering to Hope lab and renewed
contact Robin if they were okay did you
give them one dollar bills for
participating yeah I'm gonna be honest a
bit more than thing yeah okay
I'd rather be a subject out here here's
here's what you see subjects are giving
more money when they're asked to think
about giving their time first so when
they're thinking about Hope lab and
they're thinking about being committed
to that organization and they first
think about it in terms of donating
their time it actually elicits more
money from them then if they're first
asked to think about giving their money
so again this idea that activating the
construct of money and having that be
top of mind is hindering pro-social
behaviors and you see in fact that the
money condition is significantly lower
than a control condition in which
subjects are simply donating money
without having been reminded earlier of
time first or money first
moreover subjects gave their emails to
then follow up and be and behaviorally
donate their time and you see that that
too has a nice effect in the sense that
asking subjects first to think about
donating their time elicits more of
their time being willing willing to be
donated so in both cases reminding
people of time seems to elicit more
money and more time in terms of
volunteerism but reminding people of
money seems to hinder that and then
further they tracked it one month later
and you see a huge whopping effect here
when subjects are earlier asked to think
about doing their time they follow
through at a rate of 7% but when
subjects had been first asked to think
about donating money or no questions
were asked initially you see that that
number is much lower okay so the talk
that I've given to you today focuses on
one theme when people are reminded of
money they move into a self-sufficient
mode and what that means is that it
means it's bad for pro-social behaviors
it means that they're not helpful in
terms of money or time it means that
they're willing to work harder if it
means that they're able to be alone but
that last point makes a significant
meaningful contribution it's not simply
that people reminded of money are stingy
or lazy they are self-sufficient they're
working longer and harder towards their
own goals but unfortunately not towards
other people's goals and people reminded
of money are able to withstand pain and
don't feel the pain of social rejection
the work from Lewin ocker suggests
though that focusing people on time may
in fact be one of the remedies that
could be taken to move people into a
more pro-social mode thanks
Kevin we've just started a project in
southwest Kenya where we're working with
groups of subsistence farmers to help
them switch to cash crops and we're also
working with successful groups to use
those as a platform for a collective
action on community priorities mm-hmm
are we working at cross-purposes here
well that's what these data would
suggest me not knowing as much about the
cash crop idea as probably I should but
yeah that's what what these data would
suggest you want to make it you know
stew something that's more of a
euphemism for money rather than having
money per se be the construct that's on
top of mine because that doesn't help
community action it's interesting
because it's not the groups are really
about talking through farming for the
most part introducing new farming
techniques right but they're also a
vehicle for credit so they're not really
money focused their farming focus okay
these people are going from subsistence
to the cash crop cash crop
yeah you know the other I mean I'd have
to talk with you more about it but the
one thing that's kind of a relevant here
is that if they're focused on those
crops as being their own goal then it
might be fine
I'm not sure how the farmers are framing
what that action necessarily means about
themselves visa via the community but
I'll have to think about it or we can
talk more about the details yes Bobby we
just introduced a graphic that shows how
much money people have given and how
much time and one of your study says
that when people see how much money
they've spent it makes them feel weak
yes is that is what would you advise
would you give us is that a good or not
so good thing to have well my sense is
that that would not be a great thing to
have but I'd have to think about again
the way was framed I'm thinking about
Noah's work I mean so the wonderful
thing about that particular graphic is
there's multiple things going on there
you've got this idea of spending your
own money which from my data would
suggest that that's not that empowering
but then
if the social norm is that everyone is
doing it that could offset it in a
really nice way so that is an
interesting point of contact from both
of our lines of research so I'd want to
see the way that that's framed for the
for the for the viewers you know for the
for the people we're visiting that
website just to make sure I understand
correctly so we're all these studies
from what I've heard perform to students
no not all of them no we're the ones
that were how do you account for the
fact that there seems to be a very basic
intervening variable here which is that
students have an abundance of time in a
scarcity of money in other words the
conclusions we seem to make sense in a
student environment but I'm not so sure
about the world at large
yes I'm glad you brought that up so
several of these experiments for one was
a community sample and and then in all
of our experiments we try I mean to the
best of our abilities to get at lots of
different constructs that would relate
to what you're getting at this idea of
time is not so precious but money really
is so for example across all of our
samples we asked people about the the
socioeconomic status of their family of
origin what kind of money did they grow
up with we also asked them about when
there are University students MBAs or
undergraduates we asked them about their
earning potential getting at their
future earnings some of our participants
are actually working and making some
money or have some savings and we factor
that in as well and we don't find
differences in people's behaviors as a
function of previous economic history or
financial history or expected history
nor their current earnings so we haven't
found a lot of data to support this idea
that there might be different ways of
responding depending on how much you
have money in your life but I'll admit
to that we're working with a range of
well my college students who don't have
a lot of money up into the community
sample in which you see people making
No maybe $100,000 or more but we don't
have the high high wealthy folks or
neither the quite poor folks yep yeah
just in the interest of time but thank
you very much